you're never prepared for this day to
come these four years have been
incredible I can't believe it's coming
to an end not to receiving pressure from
national power so far Nigel's world is
going exactly as planned
but it's time hey Nigel they're ready
for you this journey has had his ups and
down nots recovering from a torn
meniscus and it's missing nearly the
entire seat some people didn't think I
can make it back but I'm not here for
those people I'm here for my coaches are
the ones who spent countless hours day
and night helping me perfect my crime
derby tales very Oh Nigel that first
knot as a top 10 corner and Nigel Knott
receives his Under Armour all-american
Jersey I'm here for my parents the ones
whose never stopped believing who's
always told me I have one thing
Germantown's Nigel not put on a show at
the Nike Open I look at it as one of the
top corners in the class or three eight
40-yard dash and an incredible 46 and a
half inch vertical I'm here for my boy
the ones who pushed me for that extra we
never let me settle more than anyone I'm
here for myself for the next three to
four years I will be attending the
University of Alabama no questions